mon ami guillaume erner qui est docteur
en missiologie à votre ami guen il est
exceptionnel il a fait une chronique est
aussi producteur des matins de france et
donc il a fait une chronique ce matin en
disant que cyril hanouna non à nous
effectivement et bien devait entrer au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco est ce
que vous savez pourquoi je promets que
c'est vrai c'est pas une blague grasset
dès ce matin sur france culture
et il a 12 ce matin pourquoi parceque
vous aider parce que vous aider lalala
religieux pas là c'est là c'est la merde
à préserver voilà la culture sépharade
voilà les coutures il connaît même pas
son scoop
même si je le connais mais il le dépose
à gaz et gif orientaux sa part seulement
notamment en a trop dit en des mots
comme dark car c'est le seul et a
entendu à la radio car vous l'avez
écouté vous non non c'est le côté pas
bull a pu écouter